- You're a new TV dad, you have a baby.
- [Chris] Yeah, yeah.
- So have you ever, how often
do you change the diapers?
- Well, luckily on set,
I don't have to change any of the diapers.
- [Kelly] What?
- And when you're a TV dad,
there's like multiple children.
We have triplets.
- Yeah, we had twins
on the show that I did.
- [Chris] Right.
- That looked nothing alike, by the way.
- I'm like, there's one scene,
and then this other shot,
- Sure, sure.
- I was like, "Oh God, that's just--"
(laughing)
"Totally different baby."
But they're twins.
- Oh really? They're just,
yeah, okay, yeah yeah.
- Because babies can only
work like 13 minutes a day.
- Yeah, it's true.
- Or something like that.
- I want that schedule.
- Which is an appropriate amount
of work to make a baby do.
(laughing)
- [Kirsten] Yeah, agreed.
- Cause they didn't sign up.
- No.
- But no, I don't change
any of the diapers.
- I think that's unfair.
I wanna see an Instagram
of you changing a diaper.
(crowd cheering)
- It's not that hard.
- Seems like half are okay.
- If you have a little boy,
then you gotta make sure
that diaper goes on quick.
Let's just put it that way.
- Sure.
- Have you been peed
on in the face, I have.
- I'm sure I have, But I
got that thing on quick.
I had a whole, you know those,
this is getting maybe a little gross.
- They have little, don't
they have little caps?
- They do, I use you know those pads
when you're breastfeeding,
those little pads?
Yeah, I just use those.
So I just have those and
then slap in on there.
- We just slap it on there.
- Slap it on there.
- No, it can get kind of
messy, I want a messy diaper
that you have to change,
that's the kind of friend I am.
- [Kirsten] The poop is not fun.
- You know what, I'll do it.
- Okay, okay.